i have some incredible video to play for
you of texas gubernatorial candidate
beto o'rourke
saying to a member in the audience who
was laughing when he talked about gun
violence it's not funny to me mother
effer and i have to tell you
i
love this we actually i i've been saying
these people on the right
the currency they trade in
is ignorance
reactionary ideology
and humiliation unfortunately
and
beto o'rourke humiliated a greg abbott
supporter who laughed out loud everybody
heard it when beto described the killing
of 19 kids and two teachers in uvalde
texas
and beto reacted in a way
that is entirely appropriate given the
circumstances take a look at this this
video going viral
that
now 11 weeks
since we lost 19 kids
and their two teachers
shot to death with a weapon originally
designed for use in combat legally
purchased
by an 18 year old
who did not try to obtain one when he
was 16 or 17 but followed the law that's
on the books ladies and gentlemen that
says that you can buy not one you could
buy two or more if you want to
ar-15s hundreds of rounds of ammunition
and take that weapon that was originally
designed for use on the battlefields in
vietnam to penetrate an enemy soldier's
helmet at 500 feet and knock him down
dead
up against kids at five feet it may be
funny to you [ __ ] but it's not
funny
[Applause]
oh the tone and he swore oh well when
trump swears they love it
this is sort of the only appropriate
reaction
to someone laughing at a horrifying
story of gun violence sometimes you got
to speak their language i mean these are
sick people this is the currency they
trade in and reports from inside the
event are that every single abbott
supporter in the room was laughing as if
this were some kind of joke what
happened in texas i would love to see
more democrats just being able to speak
out like this
it's genuine this is better
and not cowering when these right-wing
borderline domestic terrorists
start behaving the way that they behave
are deaths funny
is gun violence funny funny how what's
funny about it now this is a really
important race in texas pedo o'rourke is
challenging the uh incumbent lunatic
republican governor greg abbott the
polling is not
tremendously great for beto right now
but i think this one is very much worth
fighting for if you look at an average
of recent polls
abbott is ahead by just shy of eight
points right now is it abbott's got
about half the vote betto's got about 42
so
this is i mean listen let's not
sugarcoat it this is not the easiest
margin to overcome but it's certainly
possible and it would be absolutely
extraordinary to be able to take this
one from republicans so that's what's
going on in texas
good for beto guys this is the this is
the understandable frustration that we
all should have
with people who laugh at gun violence
they laugh and they want to do nothing
about guns doors they'll talk about
windows sinks showers and toilets
they'll talk about but not guns
one of our long time sponsors is monk
pack the keto friendly granola bars and
nut and seed bars i keep these stocked
in my pantry all the time the texture is
great the sweet gooey goodness is
fantastic but each bar has only one gram
of sugar or less just two to three net
carbs and under 150 calories my favorite
lately has been sea salt dark chocolate
people know about my love affair with uh
dark chocolate but you can also get
other flavors like caramel sea salt
peanut butter dark chocolate and others
then you've got the monk pack granola
bars in flavors like coconut cocoa chip
blueberry almond and honey nut i don't
do keto myself but they are a great on
the go snack if you love something sweet
and delicious but without the sugar
which is what i'm going for they just
hit the spot and if you don't love monk
pack as much as i do they'll refund all
of your money just email them my
audience gets 20 off your first purchase
at monkpack.com
when you use the coupon code pacman at
checkout the link is down below